because jamble hovich
is an absolute monster you know and he's
got massive knockout power great
wrestling
and that asanya we all know how good he
is i mean what he did to coaster i mean
that was an absolute masterpiece just
picked him apart and just destroyed him
really but
coaster was he was a little intimidated
by the speed coaster
but blejovich isn't going to be
intimidated i can't see that man
being intimidated just knocked out
dominic reyes knocked out rock hall
knocked out
uh many many people um
who's the [ __ ] uh corey anderson
cory anderson exactly yeah yeah so yeah
that's it's a really interesting
stylistic matchup because somebody like
israel larasana
is like an anderson silva they're a
kicker and they use their reach in their
range
right but if you get in their face that
kind of nullifies that
that advantage that they have you know
so they always say crowd a kicker so you
got to go forward and put them on their
back foot
if you allow somebody like anderson to
stand in the middle of the octagon
control the range and control the
octagon you're always going to have a
tough time but if you can put them on
the back foot
it gets a lot easier now of course
easier said than done because you're
going to walk through strikes you've got
to use
faints and head movement to get on the
inside you can do that
that's the way you beat somebody like
that so that's why this weekend's going
to be a ridiculous fight i
i don't think that that's gonna be the
the solution to the problem because
you know i look at the way that whitaker
fought izzy and whittaker came forward
and got knocked the [ __ ] out where'd he
get whitaker had a [ __ ] awful fight
there steve oh
you leave the fight analysis
i'm a big fan of robert he's a great guy
i've got so much respect for him
but that night against israel arasana he
was [ __ ]
the reason he did because right he tried
to go forward but what he did was
he was leaping with a left hook he was
leaping in
that's not how you do you got to walk
them down you got to use head movements
faints whatever draw out a reaction out
of your opponent so then when they throw
and you're not there when the arm comes
back that's when you go in
you don't just jump in sloppy from a
distance like whitaker was doing but as
i say as i say you you're new to this
steve no problem
and izzy's a big favorite over over yawn
yeah absolutely and i see why 20 you
know you know
20 an hour against the opposition that
he's beat that's an incredibly hard
thing to do uh and i'm not making a
prediction because i'm working the fight
but
i think it's a hard fight for is it i
also think it's a tremendously tough
fight for jan behovic you know both of
them
have got a really tough fight on the
hands uh if if you look at the skill
sets izzy's got the speed
he's got the the technique he's got the
finesse he's got the swag he's got all
that type of stuff on the flip side
you've got behovic he's not as fast but
he's a bigger guy
he's a stronger guy and he hits hard and
he does have an ability
of finding the mark as so when you break
it down like that yeah i think
izzy has the advantage i think he's
probably
correctly the betting favorite but it's
not going to be easy
it's not going to be easy at all and if
you can put him on the back foot you can
get him up against the fence
see that's why backing people up against
the fence is so important because if
you're in the middle of the octagon if
you're swinging punches
well they can just back up right but
when you back them up against the fence
they can't back up any further they got
nowhere to [ __ ] go and if you trap
them against the fence and then you
could unleash
well then you got a problem wow any
chance that uh
meegan anderson wins against nunes
nobody beats nina's right nobody and
then uh
and then yon and all joe i i'm guessing
yawn's probably a big favorite
i i haven't seen the odds yet i'm
working this one for espn this week so i
gotta i better get my [ __ ] together
but um al jamaine is such a good
wrestler you know and
anytime you're a really really good
wrestler like that it's such a great
skill to have
you know sort of peorian not as good a
wrestler
let's see how his takedown defenses if
the fight stays on the feet
the yan's tough as hell on the feet you
know but but alger man
isn't going to come in there and just
try and stand with him he's going to mix
things up he's going to stand and he's
going to shoot takedowns then he's going
to go back to the strike and then he's
going to go back to the takedowns
he's going to mix things up nicely so i
think that's going to be a really
competitive fight
thank you so much for watching this clip
and guess what
i have the number 30 ranked hot sauce on
all of amazon
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude